hey by the way I heard you left both of
you I didn't know you had two phones
still I thought you don't always have to
I heard you text me on one and call me
on it I do yes oh I don't even know that
all I know is you left both of them at
work
yeah how do you do that don't you
brought them into the studio which I
don't normally do let me ask you this
one is I assumed like a backup phone why
wouldn't you keep the backup phone in
your bag so at least you have one phone
we that's what I said to myself after
yesterday I said never take both of them
out why would you take your fine don't
ever take my phone out here I was
looking for something in both phones
well I just took both of them out and
why do you have my phones both I just
got used to doing it you know I used to
do a lot more international travel and
one of them was great for calling home
away well like the president oh my god I
heard it created chaos here that your
assistant was calling over and then well
you nobody uses their phone we were
trying to call Ronnie Ronnie
yeah because Ronnie was right here he
could have just grabbed the phones and
put them in a safe place for me yeah
good then I know Jason got involved and
it was like World War 3 around here
people charging around with looking for
Robins phones how to get the Robins
phones
I said Robin has two phones and she
forgot both of them Howard yeah Ronnie
wanted to come in because I think he was
not happy with Robins assessment of how
things went yesterday all right
assessment what did I say yeah she
claims she couldn't get a hold of me
right she talked to me she been told me
to go [ __ ] myself because I yelled at
her cuz she always forgets everything oh
my god wait a second wait to tell me
yeah she just was on the air here saying
she couldn't get a hold of Ronnie
exactly and you spoke to her I spoke to
her and her Drive Robin listen to the
whole story I said I couldn't get ahold
of Ronnie so then I called Dennis Dennis
called Jason and then gene tried
Ronnie's number again and Ronnie picked
up sorry you were how do you say it you
didn't talk to me Ronnie was your hero
how did I say I did doggie eat
let me finish the story I then sit down
and the second go-round I think we
called you three times before you picked
up and you believe she had two phones
she forgets everything dude
I know it's and she leaves her [ __ ] in
the bathroom could I tell you something
you know and I didn't say go [ __ ]
yourself yes you did I said go screw
yourself
by the way do you realize like we only
know about her leaving stuff here she
must leave stuff everywhere oh I can
imagine rest of the day I can't imagine
I go home I leave it at home I don't
know how she does that yeah he's yelling
at me stop being so forgetful
yeah yet she always has trouble with her
building pass right leaves it everywhere
how do you leave it you should always be
on her I have to take it out of here to
go to the restroom and then sometimes
I'm in a hurry to get back and I leave
it in the bathroom where did I leave my
chimes no the charm she always liked but
you bought it yeah